this show is brought to you by NatureBox
say goodbye to weird mystery ingredients
and start snacking confidently with
NatureBox visit naturebox.com Joey to
get 50 off of your first box that's
naturebox.com Joey right now go there
right now and get the right snacks for
2016. it's naturepocks.com
to get 50 off of your first box
show is also brought to you by anna.com
go to audit.com and use code word church
to save 10 on all of the great
optimization products like Alpha Brain
and new mood in shroom Tech Community
Sport and we'd like to welcome a new
sponsor this show is brought to you by
datsusara that's datsu Sara
d-a-t-s-u-s-a-r-a extremely extremely
high quality functional gear made with
hemp textiles they have bangs ease rash
guards and much much more they have bags
go to datsusaur.com right now and check
them out
please
take that [__] really this show
is brought to you by Nick
say goodbye to the weird mystery
ingredients and start snacking
constantly Jesus Christ
[Music]
oh [__]
May 9th [__] Post Mother's Day
the Church of What's Happening Now
Monday
the day the devil was buried at Sea and
[__] in the ass and lit on fire and
dropped off at Cosby's house oh [__]
Owen Benjamin what's up Lisa yet
Uncle Joey get those shoes on [__] oh
[__] pump out those moves [__]
what what what what what what what
what's the story at least saying I'm
doing good oh my God these stars are
kicking in fast yeah we're not [__]
around I've been fermenting these you
know what I'm saying these have been
sitting in the dark on Benjamin what's
happening just uh the stars are kicking
in pretty hard [__] yeah that wouldn't
even let you eat the second one because
I know these things smack people around
really hard but it's Monday night we
gotta kick out the jams brothers and
sisters
great weekend last weekend I hope
everybody's weekend was great at least I
had what'd you do I had a kind of an
easy weekend but like Paula's on a
cruise with her mom since she's
finishing law school so just kind of
hung out just watched uh I watched The
Dice Man cometh after after that podcast
on Wednesday that was great and uh yeah
that was I had a pretty low-key weekend
how about yourself me too I didn't do
dick I did the spot Saturday night
besides that hung out with the family
Sunday I want to go to Mother's Day she
went to church I went to jiu jitsu I
called her she goes I don't feel good to
come home so all our plans were broken
because she gets some migraine headaches
and that was my [__] weekend that was
I didn't do [__] I wrote a little bit
did a couple jumping jacks nice I went
down to the [__] Comedy Store what
else you want from me that's what you do
people expect that you want a jet set
and oh I went down to the Bahamas and
hung out with Pete I don't do none of
that [__] amazing how many people do
that though like on a weekly basis
they're like oh I'm going to San Diego
for the weekend or I'm going up north
it's like in every weekend thing out
here yeah it's basically like I'm gonna
go sit in a little tube in the sky
because that's what you're doing you're
like traveling most of the vacation if
you do like a one nighter what's the
point it's like a nine hour flight for
like to sit at a beach that just looks
like your Beach right two days
I don't know I never had all that energy
yeah I didn't have well like when you
grew up in the east coast you always
have that weekend outing place for us it
was the Jersey Shore you know and uh
that was one summer where I would go
down but it always felt like too much
work for me you know at least that's
what it did for me there's a lot of
people I'd say lifestyle man you know
D'Agostino's sister she's on every
[__] four nights a week she's 30. I'm
not people do it but I did I'll sit here
now and go I don't know how people do it
I did the same thing just in a smaller
frame I bought a 12-pack and went home
and snorted a gram of coke by myself so
what's the [__] difference you're
still killing yourself in one way or
another it's just I don't know I don't
know I just not never been there that
scares me like I just I'm a very I don't
want to say anti-social but I like being
by myself and the thought of being out
like I never understood that in college
when they went out four nights a week I
I would never want to be out with people
four night like in a big bar or
something it's I don't know it freaks me
out a little bit yeah I'm too tall to go
places
six seven damn it so it's like yeah
people are always bumping into me and
like taking them trying to fight them
when I'm just standing there would you
to go out a lot when you were younger
kind of not really I think just doing
comedy I've done comedy now since
college so I was always uh traveling so
I never really looked forward to more
it's almost like our job is people's
party so it's like you don't live in the
frat house you know you kind of just
kind of go
it makes sense I don't know I was like a
I went to get tacos last night my wife
says well I want to go get tacos and I
went to that Cactus place and next to
this Cactus is a bar called The
Starlight Lounge
and I was just waiting there you know
the phone rang one time a friend of mine
called Salami called I talked to him but
the whole time I was watching the bar
and it's like there's a bar culture
there's a nightclub culture there's all
these cultures that that you entered
their music comedy culture and people
that go to improv every night you know
there's people that
do you know when I was growing up I went
to a happy hour on Tuesdays I went to a
ladies night on Wednesday the whole
point of the evening was getting [__]
up when I was growing up when I was
growing up it was the the slump blow any
pills and [__] pass out somewhere
yeah you know and yeah [__] was
somewhere in that but we went out just
to [__] Rave and or rage whatever
that word is and have a good time but
then there's that culture that bar
culture that dirty dingy bar culture
which I have nothing against those bars
I grew up in one of those moms my mom
had one of those bars but that culture
always bothered me
that certain
they're out there smoking and their body
language
you know they got the hats on and they
got the the bar outfit on and
their body language is like look at us
we're partying we're doing something
nobody like it it just had this weird
thing like they had the four Dudes come
out and smoked and three other dudes in
the token black guy came out because
every of those bars in Studio City have
a token black dude yeah like we we like
black people we let hang Hank hang on
here you know those type of [__]
morons right that you could see right
through it but this is
looks like an Old Navy commercial yeah
it was just like it's got everybody's
represented everybody's representing hey
I'm the Arab guy but I'm just like you
guys yeah and they're drinking and I
still remember being stuck in those bars
like when I was a kid like to go get
drugs or something in the afternoon and
having to listen to that small talk used
to make me [__] sick even as a kid
sitting in my mom's bar I would look at
those people and go how do they sit
there all [__] day yeah it's like
performative it's like they're doing it
to be seen doing they'll be seen dude
because if you really loved booze you
just sit home and drink yeah they go to
a bar and they talk and they plan trips
to go [__] and then they you know their
whole conversation the next day is how
whack they got the night before
like how was it in here after I left
Hall we got whacked Billy came in and
bought shots for the house really that
tight [__] and you sit there and you're
like Jesus Christ what are they talking
about what the [__] are they talking
about they have this fake care like you
know well I don't know you know Lee
comes in here and he drinks 16 doubles
I've never seen a meat he's a [__]
donkey you know what the [__] is your
problem you're an Aoki it's just it's
just it's always driven me [__] crazy
and yesterday I saw it and it reminded
me I remember going home and eating and
telling my wife God damn what I never
understood that bar culture like I never
liked it at all and I remember still
hanging at bars and liking
the mid 80s like just living in Jersey
and going to those dumb little bars in
the neighborhood
and I don't believe in that going the
thing I'm happy the most is I don't have
to go to those [__] bars no more
listen to that dumb small talk and the
bartender talk [__] that noise you ever
work in a bar [__] yeah yeah my mom had
a bar so
my mom's my stepdad hated the bar
business
like he didn't drink
so when you don't drink you don't
understand it I always wanted to drink
when I came from Cuba all the TV shows
any TV show Dick Van Dyke any TV show
you watch always had Boozled and they
had always had bottles with no label on
them like everybody's house in America
had an alcohol tray but when you walked
in the door when you walked in the door
it used to make me feel weird that I
didn't drink yeah yes you grow up going
I can't wait the Owen comes over the
house and in those days people didn't
ask like we're not like [__] how we
are now right like now and let me get
stole these short in those days people
[__] you walk in my household and I
drink this [__] yeah I take the glass I
put the ice cubes in I pour it and I
hand it to you you wouldn't ask me if it
was whiskey a gin or Scotch you would
just say cheers yeah and [__] drink
it so who doesn't want to do that
these stars and alcohol don't mix I
don't think I've never been able to I
really don't think these Stars Weed and
Alcohol from McDonald's doesn't really
do anything yeah it doesn't it nulls it
out I think if I smoke first and drink
I'm I'm done if I drink first and I
smoked and I get sick
so it was always like a cat's 22.
but it was so weird how seeing that
yesterday
said to me Jesus Christ I can't believe
I got out of that [__] life you know
just hanging out at bars I never really
liked it but growing up I used to see
those people after the effects even as a
child I'd see him drunk
and even as a 10 year old child I
wouldn't let them talk to me
like they [__] bothered me right and
it bothered me that my mom was doing it
along with them like you know what I'm
saying yeah yeah me and my stepdad would
just go see you and we'd get in the car
and say look at those [__] losers
like I swear to God I always never liked
that [__] right and what are you gonna
do everybody listen that's what makes
the world go around that we all have a
different tastes
yeah I don't like uh the the club club
culture really either the club culture
yeah that was weird to me yeah because
it's like waiting in line to then go
into a bar I didn't understand that like
when you wait in line like people wait
in line like three hours to go
get the same booze it's at the Dive Bar
you know I never understood that I went
to I went to all those clubs in New York
growing up you know I went to Studio at
the end though and like on a Thursday
night I went to xenons and all those
dumb clubs they talked about if I said
to you I went more than once I'm lying
to you
even then they just weren't my yeah I'm
doing blood I want to talk I can't talk
when music's blurring in my ear so if I
talk to you I gotta hit you with a shot
of bad breath and then you talk to me
you got to hit me with a shot a bad
breath all night you just smelling bad
[__] breath I didn't like it I didn't
like it why does anybody like this [__]
I don't like I when I was 19 like I said
19 to 22 I went to a couple clubs after
a few drinks I would dance you know but
it wasn't like listen now in those days
let's get something straight
and even back then Uncle Joey don't wait
on lines like that culture is a culture
that's destroyed me right like I don't
get that culture at all like when I go
to Austin I love the barbecue but I'm
not waiting online yeah you don't mind
that's not my bag to wait online and
tell people we waited for an hour I
don't get like pinks like the hot dog
[__] is almost like a crazy line no no
you get a hot dog I don't do that that
place the breakfast place on Sunset on
Fairfax yeah 10 years ago Lindsay Lohan
went in there before one of her trials
so every day you'd go in there I drive
by and see a line in front of them and
me and favement a bunch of us would be
going to Dukes getting a nice cheese
omelet with [__] curly cut french
fries Coke and I see these mutts waiting
online to get [__] eggs
waiting online to get eggs
waiting online to get eggs which anybody
can make a [__] good egg and you
sprinkle it with whatever the [__] they
sprinkle on it but if that whole scene
thing why do people do that because it's
just it just appeals to their ideas you
know the place I'm talking about the
griddle yeah right across from uh the
Starbucks it's something uh Coffee Bean
on Sunset and Fairfax there's a line
there and 60 yards away there's a bagel
place that dude will make a nice bagel
on locks it makes juice jealous you
understand me she's from Arabia
somewhere she's over there [__]
putting locks on bagels with onions that
are [__] delicious there's no line
there no line nobody even or a nice
turkey with cream cheese with a tomato
every time I go in this one everything
you're saying right now sounds [__]
oh delicious incredible I don't [__]
around so I don't understand why you
would stand on that line to tell your
friends that me and Benjamin went to The
Griddle today oh my God it was [__]
fun what the [__] are you talking about
what the [__] are you and I've been
there it's a nice breakfast but it's not
worth the line no I I wouldn't stand it
all [__] yeah have you ever a place
that was great and then they changed it
to one of those places I had a breakfast
place that was perfect and then they
changed they added Crepes they they
painted everything and made it look like
it's like an old country place and it
was like it was depressing was there a
lie no no there was now it took it took
like three times as long because they
changed donors it was it's something
that Joey talked to me about a lot is
like not fake like don't fix something
that's not broken like why like it's and
that's something in my life too that
always whenever I overreact to something
it ends up like backfiring in my face
yeah it's like those species that
they'll bring in to kill like a bad
species and then it [__] makes a
worse thing oh it's the worst and it
like for I don't know about you but like
in my life it just destroys things like
if I I'm like okay I need to fix this
and so to fix this I'm gonna go eight
hours out of my way to fit and then it
ends up like not even working and if you
just let things happen I don't know it's
something I've been trying to lately
because I'll I'll overreact see but
maybe you're trying to fix the fix thing
that's true yeah yeah that and that
that's another Point yeah I don't know
what the [__] you're talking about
you're fixing things you want to do
eight hours out of the way I don't know
like let's say you had a
like a a show and it's like what you
were talking about earlier you you used
to fly in a night before
and and get ready for radio and and be
all prepared and well rested and then
the radio show wouldn't bring you
tickets so now you just usually have a
good night's sleep and you go on the
next day and it's easier and you get
just as many people coming in or more
and you don't have that stress of going
to LAX at 5 p.m and and a night away
from your fan like just stuff that you
think you need to do but it's the simple
the simpler the better at least for me
oh I see what you're saying
well even when we first started the
podcast
when you and I throw ideas you come up
with a good idea
but it's not a simple idea
you know I have to do too much work to
get to that final result right we got
three days
and you're talking about a two-year
prior you know and that's
we all do that we we uh you know
overreact that's what over complicated
yeah something it's just and it's it'll
it'll ruin something that could be great
I hate my wife's scheduling
I want to [__] choke my wife
sometimes I'm in the living room because
I'll see her do something she could do
two days from now
and it wouldn't really [__] matter
you know it drives me [__] crazy I
always ask let me see you over prepares
type thing oh she gets too wound up
okay
this morning the chick was coming in to
watch the baby Mondays is the only day
Mercy isn't going to school yeah we
bring Moana in and she helps watch the
baby while my wife goes food shopping
and then I sit for a while and want to
do some laundry and then she'll clean a
little bit one only comes in on Mondays
and Fridays
guess what my wife is doing at seven in
the morning
[__] laundry
as you're about to bring Awana in to do
it right you know what I'm saying
something about to ring her [__] neck
I see everything trash cans Friday we
went to lunch we got food but it was it
was too much food
I cut my steak in half purposely so I
would have breakfast steak and eggs for
breakfast right so it was a 12 ounce
steak I cut it in half she couldn't
[__] finish her state
and her mashed potatoes and her [__]
asparagus and something else the day
before we had made spaghetti Saturday
I said though listen I'm not feeling too
good she goes what do you want for
dinner I go there's a steak in there
there's horseradish mashed potatoes
there's this this this this this I don't
want nothing
I get up out of bed I smell [__] food
I go in the kitchen
and I go what are you cooking she goes I
made tortilla soup I go why the [__]
would you make tortilla soup
now nobody's gonna eat that [__] that's
why we had to throw away those four
[__] hamburgers right you follow me
she'll say well you didn't eat the
hamburgers and why the [__] did you make
that if you knew there was hamburgers in
there that's [__] bad scheduling yeah
it's like that's a [__] bad
scheduling totally you didn't plan the
move three days ahead you know if you
want your life to be easier
you have to cut that fat out keep that
in that well keep that fat and keep the
nut low and that's why not I believe in
less movement I'm 53. I'm halfway done I
got one from the grave one a banana peel
these are the years where you bend over
to put your shoes on also you see purple
and next thing you know you're in a box
and they're [__] throwing sand on you
so
guys like owing them myself we don't
[__] know Owen When Brad Pitt's doing
the movie and some guy slips on the
banana peel and gets hurt and they're
shooting the movie in Atlanta for 60
days
so I I'm always thinking like that
that I want to be ready for that call I
want to be ready for that call if I got
to leave in three [__] days
so a lot of times I wouldn't do like
right now oh and how many years have you
lived in L.A 13 years so you're not
doing the same [__] you did in the
beginning when you were here no you just
said before the show which I'm not
ashamed of saying either it's a bad
habit that we have this yeah because we
would never do this 13 years ago we
would never get a call for an audition
at night and go I'm going wake up in the
morning I call Lee and go Lee let me ask
you something where's Susquehanna Street
and we'll go that's two hours and it's
always trafficking there your auditions
at 9 45 what's your first impulse now
let me look at this side again guest
Star Fox
let me look at the show where it stands
number 18. hello yeah I woke up with a
sore throat I won't be able to go to my
[__] audition you see things for what
they are when you call me for an
audition for an ambiguous character now
he's a homeless guy just go in there and
be you just have fun with that do me a
favor where is it 4 30 down in Santa
Monica let me ask you a question
would you send your mother down there at
4 30 no I wouldn't and what the [__] you
sending me down at 4 30 call these
people back and say I'm available
tomorrow 11 15 if not I won't go and
it's a horrible request in our mind
but we we uh what's the what's the word
we Pro qualified the [__] thing for
some people they say that we we
pre-qualified it that we already lost
for some people like you and I I look at
it and go I was just going to change my
life right
how's this going to change my [__]
life the only thing I'm doing this for
is for insurance
that's basically it I'm doing this right
for insurance so I could hit that number
every year to get level one or two I'm
not doing this because
I really want to by the way people
Owen Benjamin just gave me a look that I
recognize
it's a look that's telling me
Oh that crazy high yes let's hit yes
yeah yeah I'm sorry no but it's cool
like all your story like water because
there's such a descriptive talker that
everything you're saying I'm like
literally seeing in my head
it's really fun well it's just so weird
on that you see things
I look at this and I go what is
I got it this shoots and like I got a
call today something about seeing me
about
it's not gonna happen right clap your
radius for travels you're smaller you're
crazy
WB in Burbank
Skype it unless I'm picking up an
envelope see me rally is not gonna work
I'll tell you on Tuesday that's where
all those cops were for OJ that's right
did you see that yeah it's so weird how
people call me oh yeah yeah we're doing
this thing Thursday I keep getting this
kid on Facebook it hits me up every two
weeks hi I got a show done at the
Playhouse theater in Santa Monica ten
o'clock at night listen that's not gonna
happen
that's not gonna happen it's at
Bakersfield in 15 minutes yeah no it's
you look at things for what the [__]
they are after a while you know you look
at your schedule you know what you're
going to want to do and what you're not
going to want to do you know this shoots
at Fox but I really want to go to
[__] Fox
sit there for four days in one of those
[__] cabinets they give you that
smell like ass and [__] and then put up
with this director telling me I can't
use that line you know what it's weird
to say oh so you go like when you when
you when your poor as a kid and then you
start doing better then you go back to
the trailer park when you become a star
is that kind of funny yeah like they're
living in trailers like it's like it's
like you end up back in a trailer a
[__] trailer and I love acting I love
all that [__] at the end of the day now
with the new after rates and [__] you
look at this and you know what time this
is I'm getting [__] in the end right
I'm getting [__] in the ass at this
unless this is a role I'm Really Gonna
enjoy doing
or unless
you know I'm doing a favor
nine out of ten times I totally a
thousand times my best part of
auditioning is booking something I hate
when I have to do the job I just love
booking it I love getting like all them
saying you booked it once I gotta go I
gotta go to wardrobe tomorrow [__]
Christ all that [__] bothers me
especially now after being here [__]
this long I'd rather you just see it for
what it is and it's a horrible attitude
I do not recommend it to anybody but
it's the same way in life
you start seeing things for what the
[__] they are
you know as you get older that boss is
really a [__] scumbag absolutely why
the [__] am I doing this job I'm gonna
put away my own money and start my own
business doing this I'm over here doing
this making this guy a millionaire you
start seeing things for what the [__]
they are so
you know with me over the years
when you first get here let's just talk
about Hollywood to just narrow it down
for people you do all these things in
the beginning you really fall for you
know how many times have you gotten up
gotten dressed to go to a meeting and
the guy tells you he's got a low budget
not an all-day movie and you got two
days on it and you want to look at the
guy and go so you couldn't tell me this
on the phone right it was that's not
gonna happen I gotta eat dinner with my
[__] face you know what I'm saying
hey priority Chef so you change you
change all this [__] and uh you look at
your time
my time in my head ever since I was a
[__] junkie the time in my head was
always valuable for some reason
it was always valuable I don't know how
people have all this time to like when
you tell me you take a train downtown
oh you take a [__] car ride to go eat
dumplings I I don't fathom that in my
mind but then I think about when I was
19 I used to take a two-hour drive to
get a [__] roast beef sandwich from
down to Jersey right
and for me like the train went up so
much the driving but the train is like
an example of what I was talking about
like trying to over
think something like oh I'm gonna take
the train to Hollywood to save time and
to save ten dollars on parking but then
you have to wait 20 minutes for the
train and then there's 18 stops and
there's a thousand people on the train
and what you save five bucks so just
might as well just drive down there
I know it's like these people that take
the train over here in North Hollywood
right they walk three blocks to park to
save a quarter
why'd you get the car right
I mean this Mercedes is back there they
Park BMWs back there
I've if I've made a monthly payment to a
BMW Mercedes I'd have him right next to
the train under the [__] cameras for
people to see that [__] car but
that's just me I figured that into that
my monthly budget hold on one second let
me call [__] Hollywood Transit and
see how much it costs to park
so I don't have to act like a [__]
yum and park three miles away so I could
save 15 [__] cents I never understood
those [__] bad listen man there's so
many things you don't [__] understand
and after a while you go you know what I
don't even have time to think about it
no more I'm just not going to pay
attention to these [__] morons no
Jesus Christ what's the mentally nothing
you're sweating yeah
um I'm just I'm just a little high
you're [__] red already what happened
Lee you're falling apart on me Paul is
gone she's on a cruise ship
eating that [__] death food they give
you on there it's scary I I didn't tell
her before she left but there's a cruise
ship right now like I just whenever I
think of something it's gonna be fun I
think if what you would say if I told
you I was doing it and after that hot
tub thing I went and I was like okay
maybe a cruise would be fun what was the
hot tub thing hot tub thing I got in a
hot tub on a Airbnb and I got a stye so
like like the only I would get the one
die he got fungus on his head I'd be the
old I'm gonna [__] you ever said
commercial with the guy with the
shingles yeah he comes in he's like he's
like not good you got it from a hot tub
from a hot tub in [__] big air beat
and beat to save 10 bucks like a [__]
Puerto Rican next time get in the hotel
and they're [__] justifiable but
you're paying 60 bucks and sleeping I
hope that what do you think these people
do with these Airbnb people you think
they really [__] scrub and dubbed the
house no if that person you know they'll
just put the [__] double sheet on
they won't wipe the top so if that
[__] nasty [__] got like ice
now he's living in the floorboard or the
headboard right yeah and that's why I
was thinking about cruises it's like
face herpes yo yeah it's the worst and
then and then it always everything
always happens with Joey like the day of
a podcast I see Joe with maybe two maybe
three times a week
and I'll be fine like and the rest of
the week I'm fine the day before I see
Joey I wake up I'll have like a huge
pimple on my way just anything to give
him an ammunition against me but like
it's this cruise ship that just docked
in Maine with like a quarter of the
people had like the worst stomach for
the normal virus or whatever that [__]
and I was like oh you can't go on
cruises
yeah they're kind of like [__] boats
they're just full there's so much [__]
in a cruise what do you think of that
playing this
pretty soon people gonna be able to get
herpes on airplanes and HIV they don't
clean those [__] things either no
either they wipe them down in between
flights you ever see a Southwest flight
[__] land you get right back on it
you don't see no smoke coming out of it
or no DDT you see Chinese people coming
out with masks and [__] you know those
[__] planes are filthy
[__] filthy those [__] planes they
don't do dick maybe at night they spray
them on international flights which I
don't know but I don't I'm not
International
so I don't know what they do on those
flights but I see when the American
Airlines when your plane has a problem
often they bring another one from the
gate I don't see people in there rubbing
down the seats in first class or in
coach or spraying anything they pick up
loose papers and fix the seat belts but
that's yeah there's like drooling [__]
everywhere because like when you're on a
long flight you get you get it dirty no
I have handy wipes I got everything I
got a little [__] sprayer with Lysol
I get I got in my carry-on [__] you I
wipe down the seat [__] you you're gonna
have to wait [__] suck I don't give a
[__] I used to work at a movie theater
they would never clean anything like
people all we would do is sweep the
popcorn under the seats in front of it
so look I don't think anyone cleans
anything no they don't clean dick and
those airbnbs a hot tub from 1940. how
many things shot loads were shot in that
[__] thing I see a hot tub in 84.
you're safe right before the air broke
out you're [__] safe now you got a
[__] hot tub you know God knows what
the [__] in it unless it's modern
yeah there's some aidsy hot tubs out
there
there is well I mean there's like some
[__] where you look at it and you're
like that's a [__] dirty hot tub oh
no those are dirty [__] those
Hotel yeah that's you going there that's
malaria from little kids little moms go
in there with [__] dirty filthy
[__] kids really I was gonna say that
hotels would be cleaner because they
have to keep them clean well if you go
to a [__] listen if you go to a
fourth season which you know I'm not
Johnny for a season but if you go to the
fourth season or one of those High
four-star chains you know where you're
not going to see that many kids
you know when I travel during the week
what do we get those three stars
whatever the [__] they give us at a
comedy club yeah I mean like the condos
these are [__] dirty oh yeah the
condos are [__] filthy but uh the
hotels that we stay at if there's kids
and they're jumping up and down the pool
in the jacuzzi you got a problem when
you go to those Four Seasons or those
higher end hotels you don't see that
many kids it's adults and business
people doing laps and we've like we've
heard a lot of stories about like the La
Jolla condo but what about like what
what are some other condos like that are
like throughout Cleveland's uh
Cleveland's got an interesting condo
what do they do well it's just like uh
right across from the strip club which
is across from the Improv and it's just
you go in there and it's just some dark
shits happening there you can just feel
it I thought the Cleveland improv has a
bad condo well I kind of like it just
because I I don't know it's kind of
convenient to [__] but it just has that
Vibe of like when was the last time you
were Cleveland
uh last year maybe two years ago Okay so
okay so this is the PowerHouse right
here right this is the PowerHouse
building where Cleveland is yeah the
strip club is right here okay it's right
across you have to like walk something
right in the river that it's on the wall
yeah it's around the water yeah and then
you walk this way here and there's a
building and this that's where the condo
still is like yeah yeah but right across
from at this little bar
there's that little dinner it's like uh
yeah it's like an Irish name or some
[__] yeah
that yeah that condo's not bad yeah I
like it but I got a face to get [__]
up
but there's just like broken [__] like
there's a broken table that was 15
[__] years ago you know that was I
the last time I was in that [__]
condo guess what I watch
the first time I ever watched The
Sopranos so in 1999 wow was the last
time I was in that [__] car no I'm
lying to you I was there
I Feel The Longest Yard
I basically went there for three days to
get [__] sizzled out of my brain that
was one of the places where
when I left the hotel room to take the
plane I was paranoid to even leave the
building like the whole ride to the
hotel I kept thinking jumping out of the
car the strip club to have a free lunch
right a prime rib lunch yeah tell me
they still have the prime rib lunch yeah
they they definitely have like a big
food thing going on
that's 20 [__] years the first time I
went there to Cleveland
was 1999 I went from Miami Improv which
was like a paradise
people doing blow people drinking people
[__] the bathrooms the bar stayed
open until two it was across the street
I'll never forget I went so I was in I
was in Miami is that Coconut Grove
coconut yeah this is when Coconut Grove
though was Coconut Grove before [__]
they turned it into all kinds that was
in the cops [__] closed it up
this is when Coconut Grove was
you know the first time I went to that
Miami Improv it was Tuesday through
Sunday
and it was the summer of 99 and the
first time I went to that Miami Improv
the way I went it was a condo yeah at
that time they were still putting me in
condos and they put me in this condo
and it was the Tuesday night show
and I got out
and they said do you want food and I was
embarrassed and I go no and I walked
back to the condo and I stayed in the
condo I was [__] starvingly and next
when I got up and I walked over and got
breakfast at the news this was did you
ever go there when that place was across
the street from at the news something
news I forget what it was and
Lee I was a fee track making [__]
four or five hundred dollars a week and
breakfast was 20 dollars
my head almost blew up my head almost
blew up you know Coconut Grove is a
heavy duty area at the time heavy
[__] duty I mean everything you know
it was three dollars for the soda I mean
there was really nothing back then
that's crazy this is crazy Lee this is
when Coconut Grove was coconut [__]
growth you know that hotel up the corner
from my Miami Improv yeah at Coconut
Grove that's where the [__] Knicks
and the NBA teams stay
that's what type of hotel it is up there
heavy duty security cameras valet
parking they had a shield the only
people who stayed there were Richard
Jenny
um I I forget they put Miami Improv only
had two Comics that stayed at that hotel
everybody else stayed at the Newport
or on on whatever the [__] it is there
but that Wednesday I went there and
again I pulled the same stunt I left
there hungry and I went back Thursday
was an eight o'clock show and I left
there again this night I said [__] you
I'm gonna find the [__] Bodega I walk
three blocks late and it was like being
in New York City
in what way people everywhere
it was one in the morning and there were
people [__] everywhere Lee
everywhere girls dancing in pizza places
I I want I kept walking the wrong way I
kept walking through a residential area
but if I walked a different way
you know and all of a sudden I bumped
into waders from the [__] improv and
waitresses and then making me go to this
other bar and next thing you know
they're telling me if I want to buy blow
for three days I sat in that room in
Miami with no blow no booze I didn't
know nobody and it became this [__]
City it was amazingly we amazing and you
could deal with the one bar where they
used to hang you get dolphin mahi mahi
on a [__] seated bun with mayonnaise
and coleslaw you have no [__] Ideo in
Benjamin Owen Benjamin is starting to
see the double lays and John I love it
that's my boy out of [__] New York
and [__] but the moral of the story was
I went from this nightlife the first
time because the second time I went to
Miami I was I was crazy
I went from there to Cleveland to where
Cleveland like January 2nd to January
like 9th it was like a seven day Tuesday
Cleveland's probably just as exciting in
early January
when I pulled up it was freezing there
was snow on the ground that went in and
the goofy dude that the door goes come
here he goes uh here's some passes you
get free
lunch at the strip club again when
you're a future act and you're getting
500 a weekly a free lunch is a free
lunch it's gonna cost you somewhere it's
gonna cost you the first time I went in
there these [__] strippers were
disgusting
and one of them was cutting the meat she
was big they had a stripper cutting the
meat she was big black and fat and she
was cutting the meat herself and putting
her fingers in it and eating it and [__]
[__]
and the [__] meat was pink and the
potatoes you know people were sticking
their fingers in their potatoes I just
ran out of there and that was it but I
had a [__] there's nothing around
that
but if you walked up that hill if you
walk to the corner and if you walk out
of that building and make a [__] left
and walk up that hill make another left
and keep walking three blocks up is
where you find civilization it's a
Puerto Rican neighborhood so I bought a
couple nickel bags and I bought some
[__] food up there and I didn't know
it that's the second biggest Puerto
Rican population in the country
Cleveland because in the 50s they
brought Puerto Ricans to work up in Ohio
on the car manufacturers so all those
Puerto Ricans stayed there not that you
give a [__] but if you ever go to
Cleveland you got a Puerto Rican friend
that's it that's what I'm telling you
that's the last time I was in [__]
Cleveland but the first time I went I
was in the condo with a headliner the
second time I went I was the headline
and I was in there by myself and I
remember watching The Sopranos Sunday
night
and like uh no you know they played for
sopranos during the week in those days
the episodes like they they play the
episode on Sunday but during the week
they kept playing it that's the first
time I was just watching TV one night
what the [__] is this do you remember
the episode
no no it was like episode five maybe
one of those it was early on but the
funny thing was when I first moved to LA
I was doing comedy I was at the comedy
so I signed with this manager named Ken
Phelps and between you and I he was half
[__]
he had uh he had a company in Georgia
and he sold it and he took the money and
just wanted to move out here and become
a comedy manager he bought a bunch of
Suits he bought a [__] Range Rover he
had the wife with the fake tits
and then he uh
he [__] sent me on little gigs and I
went to New York one time and he got me
a Showcase in governors
he got me a Showcase in Caroline's and
he called me back and he goes hey I just
got off the phone with this guy
and they want to see you in the city for
the show called The Sopranos
he goes I don't know what it's about
just make a tape
and take it to them this is the address
and I'm like I'm not dropping a [__]
tape off about singers and [__]
so I didn't drop it off see what happens
for being [__] lazy
oh and we feeling all right yeah I'm
going to get some man yeah now I'm I'm
[__] crazy high though okay you want
me to you want to move more water yeah
okay let's do some water yeah [__] I
told you you want to leave too I saved
you because I like it man I'm one of the
few guys in comedy I behave around you
and Steve Burn I like these both you're
gentleman and [__] that's why I wanted
to have you on the show every time I see
Owen Benjamin I always behave myself as
a comic I don't say a [__] work
because he's such a nice guy really
thanks you and Steve Burton one time I
flipped out in front of Steve Byrne not
at Steve Byrne I went off on a guy in
front of Steve Byrne and I'll never
forget turning around how Steve Byrne
looked at me I got in my car and almost
cried what do you do
he wasn't upset I still talked to him
about it he goes no you just I was going
through my own [__] that same guy was at
The Comedy Store Saturday night and he
gave me a canister full of weed and we
talked it was just a misunderstanding he
was a manager at the store and right I
was going through my [__] [__] in
2006. what happened
I probably went up there to get Coke and
nobody was up there and uh
a couple days earlier Paulie Shaw this
guy was Paulie's assistant back in the
day
and on Friday night my mom Paulie's show
had the show on TBS yeah Paulie store or
whatever it was on Friday night the
people from TBS were there
sitting in the audience so Paulie
started taking people off the list
who they didn't want on the west I was
one of them and Joe Rogan was one
at the time Joe had just paid for a
stereo
system for the room or some [__] I don't
know the exact story
and Joe is the reason that the room was
packed every Friday night
it really was this is back in the
Myspace days guys this is way before a
podcast
you know he he ever he had already a
great internet Presence at the time I
had no idea what an internet presence
was
so on this night
Joe went down and the room was sold out
and somebody had to tell him he wasn't
going up
as a matter of fact I was down there
first and they told me and I just waved
around to see what was going to happen
with Joe I was actually going to throw
salt in there and start a [__] riot
but it didn't happen I stood by the door
with my back to them
I heard them explaining it to him and
then Paulie came down
and he kind of started saying some
[__] up [__] what was he saying like
[__] you you know the reason why they're
here is for me they're not here for you
stuff that was just
wrong it was just totally inaccurate I'm
the type of guy if you want to talk [__]
on and you could back it talk it if
you're right you're right I'll give you
your props but if you come in here going
Joey I sell more tickets than Kevin Hart
I gotta look at you and go oh
you know what I'm saying stop it Owen
stop I like you what are you [__]
busting my ball for you know I ate six
stars uh
uh how can you handle six times because
we're in training on Benjamin you
understand me I'll give you a bag to go
and then you'll be in training you'll be
a soldier of the church this is people
who see it and now when they see it
they'll bring you something for your
baby and the best edible that city has
to make
and they're gonna say we heard you on
the church here you go you're in
training nice I'm trying hard
yeah they'll bring you acid mushrooms
all the fun stuff yeah you could take in
the hotel room by yourself right where's
my [__] mind sure wouldn't iPod yeah
let's run some Pink Floyd just [__] it
that's it it's over we don't do that
much [__] no more like that we don't go
back to the room and put music on and
sit there and meditate
but uh what are we talking about no so
they were going off on Joe I turned my
back
just so I if I had to take a lie
detector test always turn your back on
Benjamin so you could say I really
didn't see nothing I turned around he
was on the floor I don't know nothing
but wouldn't they say like didn't did
you hear him hitting somebody I don't
know I don't know life had to touch okay
they can't commit they just the main
thing is do you see anybody get hit no I
didn't why not there was a [__]
shooting star
I gotta teach you everything at least I
had so I turned my back I thought it was
going to go down this guy wasn't a bad
guy my head was in the wrong place
I was a little sick and tired of The
Comedy Store I didn't like what they had
done that night and to be honest with
you you never like to see your friends
get [__] on for no reason
so I kind of felt bad but I always had a
lot for that guy
and I always had it out for paulium one
night I went through the store maybe a
month after that and he said something
to me and I took it the wrong way and
started going off on them
grabbed each other and we yelled at each
other and you know I said some dumb [__]
and then when I turned around Steve
Byrne was right there
I never felt so [__] embarrassed in
my life
I always apologize to him after that for
going off on somebody like him but the
guy was going off on me
and I left the store shortly after that
and didn't go back
until about a year ago and sadly
as I walk in the check and he's sitting
in the back row
and
I came down I went to the bar and got a
water when I came back he was in the
hallway he gave me a big hug I asked him
how Hawaii it was he says he moved to
Northern California
and he said he brought me some goodies
and he gave me a little film canister
like the 80s filled with this [__]
pretty good reefer he said he face
brother found the seed in the garage
sale or something and it was an
Afghanistan season he's been growing and
[__] ever since so sometimes you know
it was water under the bridge yeah good
ending what are you gonna do yeah you
could only try talk to me about this
Piano Thing what do you want to know
yeah I I said I played piano and you
looked like that you wanted to play oh
it killed me when I was a kid my mother
baptized a girl and I would spend my
Summers with those that girl's family in
Miami
mom was a big time college professor in
Cuba
and after she got married and stuff and
she had kids and she might you know she
she exiled to the United States
now that she had kids she wasn't a
teacher or Professor anymore but she
still had that uh
State of Mind
so what I would spend my summers in
Miami she would basically tell me by the
way from 9 to 12 here every day we do
school work
like there's no [__] going out and
playing there's nothing you got two
options you could either do school work
you go now be a laborer for Rodolfo
and you know like wait a second so I can
if I be a laborer for rodolf I got to be
there all day when I'm picking up boards
and getting bit by dogs and shoveling
and [__] or I could stay here and do
three hours of school work even at that
age I figured out it would help me so I
would stick around but she had three
kids
me and the two kids would do school work
while the girl played the piano
and let me tell you something my mother
would [__] chastise her to no [__]
end
for Perfection because she was doing
no no that's that's that [__] another
song she was doing some [__]
Tchaikovsky type thing at some college
at the age of 12.
but I'll never forget how much the
mother used to torture that girl how
much they went back and forth but the
discipline that she had to have always
stuck in my mind
yeah mine wasn't my upbringing wasn't
like that I was playing I just played
all yeah that's what I was drawn to it's
like we didn't have a TV for part of my
childhood so we just had a piano and my
dad sang Opera so that's how we got
along and I just I just liked it I
always liked playing it
and I professionally never thought about
it no I mean I had my piano teacher uh
was a woman named Lucinda and when I was
11 for Halloween she went as a dude uh
and then she got a sex change so I
always thought it was funny because it's
like if you're gonna first have a sex
change do it on Halloween because it was
like an easier transition
but so then I got taught it was the same
person taught me as a woman and then as
a man and that's why I got fascinated by
like gender because it's like I got to
see a whole different brain
you know it's like on testosterone it
was a much different person now what
year was this 1991
I'm around that time either 60 Minutes
of 2020 had a whole thing
I had just gotten separated and I was
home and I was miserable
and 2020 had a thing about a woman the
whole transition the man yeah so she was
a woman first and then became a man yeah
what was her new name Larry still
friends with him great dude
but yeah it was uh how was his life now
is he married
uh yeah he has a wife boyfriend wife
uh yeah just chilling just happy plays
piano
I don't know all that [__] I don't know
it's it's fascinating how old were you
when when you were when that happened
11. you got balls of steel kid around
the same time it wasn't a piano teacher
but my friends my Dad's friend had a
friend who like we'd always be at their
at this place and it was a guy who was I
don't know if he was transitioning to be
a woman but he was dressing like a woman
and it was like it didn't freak me out
but I was just I was thinking I was
around that age I just didn't understand
it
was like fusing yeah
see I grew up with dudes who put wigs on
and just put Scotch tape around their
dick and took their Channel
I don't know if they did the complete
check and sometimes you'd see him and
have glasses on with a suit and
sometimes you see them they were clean
shaving with a wig on you know it was
always an adventure Spanish people got
wild imaginations they just don't commit
you know the whole [__] I've never
really known anybody who made the
transition in front of me that's very
interesting
because I see all this transgender stuff
and now you hear about North Carolina
and all the bathrooms and I'm in the
back of my mind I'm going
I don't see these many transgenders
right all right you go to Hollywood by
Yum Yum Donuts that's right there on
Beverly that's that's where it's
crackalacket that's where you see the
whole neighborhood
but but and they're not even really not
full committed you could tell that they
just they're just Weekend Warriors
Weekend Warriors and [__]
we can weekend Weekend Warriors
[__]
did he ever explain himself to you and
pull you aside and go listen next week
it's gonna be a [__] up week
now that's why she did it on Halloween
because then it was like oh but you
didn't skip a beat like there was no
there was no hint like there was no
listen we never even talked about it I
think I was right at that age where I
you didn't give a [__] I didn't give a
[__] I literally didn't care at all so I
just it just never came up really
trying to think if I ever my mom and
friends that were gay like flamingly gay
you know but nothing
to that that I was you know I knew a guy
that put a wig on
that freaked me out a little bit you
know it took some time to adjust that
ass if you beat it but besides that I
never really had somebody who I thought
there was a lot of preparation into
having a gender operation I thought that
there was a lot of uh psychological you
have to go through a year psychological
evaluation
they give you hormones right now where I
live the people across the street from
me they're dabbling in something ah I
don't know what the [__] it is I have no
idea he says he's a pilot I'm one of
those try the planes listen
if you're a man and you come into my
plane as the pilot as Lucille on Monday
I can't trust you with my [__]
playing right I can't you you're
confused you're not confused I don't
know I just can't I'm not saying nothing
bad I'm just saying that he's been home
a lot more since he became a woman I
tell you that much and
he gains a lot of weight I don't know if
he cut his dick off I know his hair is
down I know the cheekbones are high
I know that his voice changed a little
bit and I know he stays in a lot more
tremendous yeah those things are strong
yeah you just relax this is the devil
here tonight this is it this is as good
as it gets Pete what's a [__] Monday
night I'm the Church of What's Happening
Now where's Tony Bennett did you even
line it up tonight no you didn't see
you're [__] slipping Lisa yet
that God owned Benjamins on the showtime
let's smoke this [__] Bowl well at
least I had does this thing you want to
take a hit of this old Benjamin this
will get the blood pressure again
this is it baby
the [__] life
you guys get this hat is this like weird
no
you'll be on the ceiling right now
whatever
I gotta go uh yeah
yeah they're calling you a new Soldier
In Training that's right you got like
eight Stars you only started I don't
know yeah [__] yeah that's it you're the
man of steel tonight
so for what happened to Tony Bennett
that was quick I turned him off because
you're coming back no I'm just I just
went to open the door to give my main
man some man
cause I've been where he's been
that guy you didn't pop the second one
he wanted to eat another one I go no no
no just see how this one tastes like you
know I know you live down the beach I
see out of the night smoking I figured
you could handle it relax for a little
while you ain't driving you can't drive
right the car you gotta go all the way
to the 90. forget about it
I got a probiotic in here I got some
green juice
how long do those usually last for
only a couple hours oh yeah you're all
right is it for a while sure
value
oh yeah we don't [__] around here
the church what's happening now today
I thought you [__] knew that's why I
asked you when you called it
smoke some Reef I remember one night I
saw you out there
puffing and [__] yeah no I like I like
vape pens and [__] which it's the it's
the Edibles that I I haven't done in
edible in a [__] while oh then yeah
this is a this is like [__] watching
a Hitchcock movie you know I'm saying
this is like you're in the birds right
now you see uh Jungle Book 3D
I think I am right now yeah
then relax just sit tight we got your
back just drink some water let the air
open for you so you don't get anxiety
have you seen Captain America yet Joey
oh yeah yeah you should have seen me
going up and down and [__] going my
little shirt on get the [__] out of here
I got better [__] to do than want to see
[__] Captain America look at the
reefer was smoking tonight we're out we
are Captain America
this is it don't get no better than this
what are you gonna do it's a Monday
night here
it's a Monday [__] night can you
imagine running with Uncle Joey on a
Friday you have a heart attack
where are you going this week this week
I'm going to beautiful [__]
Sacramento California that should be fun
very exciting I like that little room
it's a small room look at the sushi
joint I got Red Lobster and I got the
habit I got the menu planned for three
days you understand me they give you
that little half a Hindu breakfast at
the hotel the egg smell like [__] God
knows what close your eyes you inhale
them and you pray for the best
at lunch time somebody picks you up you
go for a little walk around the
neighborhood and at night you got Red
Lobster with a bunch of black people who
I love nobody's more passionate about
[__] Red Lobster than black people in
Sacramento they go bananas in there that
one specifically they love you oh yeah I
used to right when Paula and I first got
together she lived in Inglewood and when
I would drop her off on Sundays we'd go
to eat sometimes and they had a
Applebee's and Red Lobster and black
people that would come out in their
church clothes I I used to get one I
used to like I used to sometimes tell
the mom to not cook be so we could go
and and watch but like it was the best
thing I've ever seen
Applebee I didn't we never went to Red
Lobster but Applebee's was hysterical
they had a Red Lobster on Wilshire
Boulevard no they didn't really yes they
did years ago years ago me and my wife
came back my wife picked me up at the
airport this is what me and my wife
lived in the one bedroom with the
[__] 19 cats
I made like a bonus somewhere and I
remember going let me take you out to
lunch I took it to that Red Lobster and
it was filled with black people I loved
it I mean I didn't get pissed off
yeah they were dancing they had the
whole [__] thing oh and Benjamin
coming back
he's coming back he's making a comeback
like Jerry Lewis
good [__] these stars are the stars of
death the home Benjamin
trust me I'm [__] up right now myself
how many did you take you I took what
six five years sure [__] do you guys do
that this is don't
this is it we we've been in training
right now for about for almost four
years five years
Lee started at 30 Edibles and smoking
hash out of a can look who he is today
he's a successful podcast tour and he's
eating [__] 700 milligrams a week
who's better than a week a night
whatever the [__] but you're having a
good time you're in training yeah you're
breathing you're throwing up kettlebells
yeah that's I'm really bummed out that
I'm like this is the first time in a
sport that I've actually kind of like it
and we've been doing snatches and I suck
at them so like today I was watching
videos it's weird I get competitive with
myself with that stuff and I don't like
that I'm not good at it well here's the
good thing about where you're going the
good thing about where you're going that
he's he's got a great philosophy she's
amazing he's an amazing guy he's an
ex-new York firefighter and he's
committed his life to this if you see
this guy I'm his age or he's four years
old
tell him what he was doing the other day
hanging from like he does pull up hangs
for like three minutes he just hands
this guy's an amazing [__] oh yeah uh
sweetheart of a guy Dave is a sweetheart
of a guy
but he's got a different philosophy to
training especially the guys like myself
and Lee we're not looking to go to the
Olympics he's like look whatever you
can't do you can't do today
but a week or two you'll be able to do
he gets mad if you say can't yeah he'll
make other people do push-ups
so it's just really weird that's the
philosophy as also Lee and I trained
before you want to take a walk here
right yeah get some air right there get
somebody on the background and take your
water with you just in case you [__]
uh you know you want to dehydrate a
little bit you'll be all right
this happens it's the best it's it's
it's better than the people who like
don't take it yeah people love you
you're a hero so the the the problem is
here that his philosophy was a
it's not going to work today let's
modify the movement
so you could get it right that's what he
would say he modifies the movement right
yeah absolutely at least you can work on
that muscle and B he had a different
philosophy when it came to kettlebells
he has he had a philosophy of he never
wanted to over train you
know a class today was like 35 minutes I
I stayed after the practice he never
really wanted to over train you he
always wanted you leaving going really
that's it yeah get the [__] out of here
stretch your back and get the [__] out
of here and it may so it's gone with me
now today like today I was supposed to
do kettlebells but I got busy I took a
nap I had to go get my head [__] done
for this thing on Wednesday I had to do
a thousand things little stupid busy he
abandoned [__]
oh
this is the real deal at church you know
I don't think he knows the code I think
I think we're okay no he's okay
this is heavy duty that those [__]
stars we as a matter of fact give me the
bag I'm gonna eat another one out of
respect for this poor kid okay
what do you think I'm not eating it
alone no like my partner in crime
out of respect for you people you know I
love you all my heart I hope you have a
good week
I mean it's starting to [__] solo tip
just to let you know we ain't [__]
around no more
2016 is the year the church [__] all
right take it a [__] leave but I
ain't got time for this [__] no more
your attitude should be like my attitude
it's over we're taking over this [__]
right or wrong [__] sucker where you
drinking water for absolutely huh you
wanted a plane or something what's with
the water I was drinking I was drinking
okay
um nobody and he he was just saying like
you have to
he's have to start somewhere and it's
but it's like this is the first time in
this that I've struggled like I've
struggled with certain
aspects of it but this is the first move
that I really just I'm just sucking at I
can't believe the dynamic that working
out has added to my stand-up in the last
seven years
like if you look at my career
my career really started rocking and
rolling as a personal for me when I
started working out
it gives you an extra form of confidence
you feel like you're standing higher
after 90 days if you stick with a
routine or something you do feel [__]
different they don't tell you that just
for their health I don't I'm not telling
you this because I'm telling you this
because I'm living it right now right
you know a year ago I couldn't go to two
jujitsu's in a week just couldn't do it
now you're going to two in a day now I'm
going to two classes in a day sometimes
you know tomorrow I'm gonna go to one
and Wednesday I'm gonna go to two
you know it's always something I always
I'm doing something but it's amazing you
know what little strides become you know
little commitments become big [__]
commitments I've always [__] said
that
but I can't believe the dynamic working
out has added to my life in general
it gets me perked up it makes me stick
to all my other goals
like if I could go somewhere and wrestle
for an hour
I could for four hours I could do so
many [__] things I write so much in
the afternoons now it's [__] pathetic
is it because you overcome a lot of fear
like that's what we were talking about
today is like the my he thinks my main
problem with it is I'm just scared of of
it getting close to my head so I'm
trying to catch it so and I know you've
talked about Jujutsu is to get over your
fear of like the breathing so is that
like overcoming a fear just like
motivates you yeah but I also realized
something today I'm gonna have surgery
in July for my nose tomorrow I'm gonna
go for a seat scan at 10 9 30 in the
morning okay and it's so weird how today
was the first time that I really
realized that somebody said to me a
couple weeks ago
but I do struggle when I breathe from my
nose I can feel it now when I walk
because ever since Dr belisa came in
here and I read the book I've been
working more on my breathing exercises
and I can feel it now sometimes when I'm
breathing in
that you know it's not as strong it's
not as strong because I'm struggling so
now I'm looking forward to having this
[__] surgery and once it's gonna fix
your nose and you should be able to
breathe normally because a lot of people
have told me they said listen man my
friend had that now his life has changed
completely
like Dr belisa said oxygen is oxygen
because you're not getting it if you're
struggling to get it that's why your
blood pressure is high there's so many
[__] valuables from it could this fix
your sleep apnea maybe I don't think
it's gonna fix the sleep patent me I
really don't
you know eating through all this working
out over the last seven eight years that
I've been doing
the sleep apnea has come and gone as far
as
what I'm able to do when you're at your
lightest do you still have it like when
you were at like 260. 270 yes I still
had it I was that's interesting okay I
was falling asleep on planes
if you had the FL sleep on my couch [__]
I forgot to call this guy today
fell asleep yesterday and this poor kid
called me two days in a row the one day
I got caught up doing something
yesterday I could fall asleep on my
chair now
and you couldn't do that before no what
would happen I would choke
right away yeah
I could sleep for 40 minutes and I don't
wake up scared that I'm not sleeping
with the machine and it really shocks
myself
the other night I was telling you I woke
up in the middle of night
I had to sleep out in the machine up and
I ate those edibles
right okay and
we ate the star late like tonight like I
just [__] up because that last started
in the morning right yeah I'm gonna wake
up huffing and [__] puffing all
goddamn night so
when I got up at night from being
uncomfortable I peed and when I went
back to bed I could feel my heart
beating from the other bowl and I could
feel
that we're still a little bit High
and all of a sudden my mind played with
the emotions from the edible
in what way because all of a sudden my
mind started coming up with [__] up
thoughts like my mind said to me what
happens if the sleep apnea machine
breaks right now
and all of a sudden I started getting
anxiety just thinking about that do you
know you're high and then it's
ridiculous or do you get swept up in it
because I'll get swept up in it
sometimes
if I get I'll get so swept up and I
gotta take the mask off and stand up and
go outside and get air and walk around
and then what pisses me off about that
what frustrates is that now I'm awake
and now I'm thinking about tomorrow I'm
going to be ineffective in so many
[__] different areas because I got to
stay up for two [__] hours this is
what comes to my mind and it's a
never-ending Circle level circle of what
comes into your mind and once I'm laying
horizontally and I get fear I can feel
my blood pressure and my tension and my
heart beating
so if I'm laying on my left side I could
feel my heart [__] bump and I gotta
flip over and by that point now my mind
is taking over now my mind is telling me
this could be the beginning of a heart
attack
so I get up and I pick up the [__]
phone like the [__] and I get my robe
and I stay in the living room and wait
for the [__] world to end and then
nothing happens I get pissed off I go in
I drink an aspirin I [__] drink some
water you do not have an aspirin yes I
do and then I sit down right like a
[__] Momo and I sit there in the
living room by myself
and eventually one of the [__] cats
will come over because that's that peak
hour so they want to get petted and I
get frustrated at first and they jump on
my lap but then I go you know what wait
a second he may be on to something
because it might be My My by me patting
this little [__] cat
my anxiety might go away and sure enough
it goes away so then now I'm wide awake
I'm playing with super bad it's usually
Super Battle Demi that torment my life
so now I turn the TV on I'm watching
sometimes I got vinyl on DVR I've been
watching the people versus O.J Simpson
again I was watching that
and then guess what it'll do guess what
guess what the genius that Uncle Joey
does oh no you don't take another edible
dude no I wouldn't I'm not even that
smart I get up and go outside and I
smoke two bowls of weeds guess what
happens now it's 3 15 in the morning I'm
sitting there and my world is ending
it's collapsing I can't [__] breathe
and I gotta drink [__] a gallon of
water to calm down the living room and
then buy two bowls who knows Lee who
knows cause I'm a [__] idiot and then
I [__] and then I [__] uh three in
the morning Benjamin abandon ship
the stuff is here no
no that's my sweatshirt
oh
well thank you for coming on no I don't
know maybe he's outside
mind your business
so that's what I [__] do so now I
gotta sit there for another hour while
my heart's beaten
and I gotta take one of those [__]
anxiety pills that Dr gave me one was
Larry pills and then I [__] calmed
down I go back and I sleep like a baby
till like 7 30 and my wife wakes me
after I'm running late I'm telling you
it's gonna happen tonight because I got
to be somewhere at 9 30 tomorrow morning
I never got to be somewhere in the
mornings I have a horrible [__] night
yeah I can't sleep when I got when I
don't gotta be somewhere next morning
I'm like Johnny [__] tired once I
know I gotta [__] be somewhere I'll
listen I'm insomnia Joe I can't [__]
sleep so many characters oh please
there's a thousand [__] characters in
my world I got insomnia Joe I got
[__]
Johnny sleeping Johnny sleepy you know I
got like 10 [__] characters in my
[__] personality
I would fail on match.com with those
[__] morons what's your personality
18 of them you need like 10 different
Lincoln accounts Johnny rifa you know
[__] Joey bad in bed Joey one minute
I like it what's up with you buddy
just trying to put the pieces together
like I said I've been trying to write a
lot more
trying to just get my fitness going a
lot more you know just trying to uh
stick with what I'm doing over there has
Jiu Jitsu been going
listen
I have bad days and I have good days but
the most important thing is that I'm
consistent and that was the ultimate
goal in doing this the same reason why
you joined the Kettlebell gym first of
all I know you give somebody a yard
you're going to be that 801 yeah
absolutely [__] yeah I know you so uh
this whole thing taught me a lot this
comedy thing it taught me a lot it
taught me how easy life is even though
it was very hard
because it taught me that sticking with
something
and
how hot that
overcoming if if I if right now I look
at the first eight years of my comedy
right I gotta tell you how hard it
really was like if you said to me Joey
this is what you're gonna do in the next
eight years
I tell you I'm not gonna [__] do it
but I do it all over again
and because I did this it helps me
understand
how easy the system works how easy Life
Works and this applies whether let's say
you want to be a baker or a mechanic
or whatever you know listen man
uh yeah I could walk into whatever
motorcycle technology or automobile when
you're 14 if that's what you like doing
you're 15. look at this kid Cassius
Morris
I wish I had the [__] brain that that
kid had at a young age right because
people this is easy it seems like it's a
long time
when you come to me at lunch time ago
Joey can I ask you a question what are
you making out when I say I make 15 an
hour and you go [__]
I'm making six
how long before I get to make 15 an hour
and you're like uh I've been working
here for seven years you're like [__]
[__]
seven years for nine bucks you know but
then you a smart [__] will say
well
I could work here learn to trade at the
same time
and who knows what will happen in seven
years
I could open up my own thing
but the main thing is I don't think
about the money right now
see that's what I used to get caught up
in when I was young I used to get caught
up how much are they paying me now
because I never thought there was going
to be a tomorrow
I always thought they were kidding me
but there really is a [__] tomorrow
but how do you especially when you're
young you need the money now so how do
you focus how can you focus on tomorrow
when rent's due tomorrow
putting the [__] blinders on
by putting blinders on and going you
know what I'm gonna stick with this
because something good is going to
happen and then now guess what happens
Lee that job you were doing five days a
week one of the guys from that shop
recommended you so you could do weekend
work somewhere else and you could make
10 bucks an hour now at that place
and you look at me and you go Joey but
I'm working seven days a week listen
anything that you want to be good at you
got to do seven days a week
I wish I'd go to Jujitsu seven days a
week my body just can't handle it I went
to jiu jitsu Sunday it was basically an
easy [__] class
I rolled one time then we had to get out
of there for Mother's Day I [__] had
a hard time walking around I took a
leaves and [__] today so if you were 25
you'd go seven days a week yeah
not even to compete just as an exercise
just to take my mind off my everyday
grind
if I had to pick something right now at
this age if somebody came to me at 25
and said listen
I I want to take my mind off the every
any everyday grind what should I do I'd
say
go to that particular Jiu Jitsu school
and tell do everything he tells you to
do
watch the strongest guy in there and do
what he does it's just like life
if you're an engineer and you want to be
a good engineer you're going to hang out
with the dude that calls in sick the
dude that does blow no you're gonna hang
out with that Chinese dude over there
that comes in an hour before and stays
till 10 o'clock at night that's why he
does what he does
because eventually all that time will
pay in you're clocking in you're not
clocking in at your job you're clocking
in on the clock of life
and the clock of life always [__]
remembers
it really does
if you think I would tell you this when
I was 30 you're [__] crazy okay let
me okay but let me tell you who told me
this
slash
I'm not friends with Slash I don't know
slash I don't know this phone number I
don't know how to get a hold of them I'd
bump them through them once at the
Riviera I was I had insomnia it was
insomnia Joe I had no drugs
at that time Rogan didn't smoke weed so
I had I didn't have no weed so I'm
walking to this [__] hotel and there
was like a pinball tournament or
something like a convention and he was
there slash was just roaming the pinball
he was with the convention but that
night he was at the bar
and he was just standing there and I
asked him I saw him I was a fan that I
had seen him at the comedy club on
Sunset one night when we used to do
comedy at that place where I met I met
used to hang I thought you used to run
um
and I saw him there one night I said
hello and he was very nice and I asked
him why Guns and Roses broke up and
he said you know he said what you're
going through right now this is how long
you've been doing comedy
he goes are you making money I told him
the truth I said I'm in Vegas I'm gonna
make 200 for the weekend
I'm doing two shows I got 200 in a plane
ticket and I got a [__] past eating
the employee hotel
not even in the buffet listen to me not
even in the buffet and you were told to
explain what the employee of food is
that's where all the food that don't get
eaten in the buffet goes to like pieces
of chicken with a bike taken out of it
that people that they put back I'm
joking it's a joke people but
the point of this was that he told me
that
what you're doing right now has a payoff
and some people that's why you have to
do this hard work so when the payoff
comes you don't analyze it
that's what gets people in trouble
you ever see a character you like in a
movie right and
you uh
don't see him ever again and one day you
ask around or you Google his name and it
says that
you know he just got hooked on drugs or
something
and disappeared
somewhere there was something something
couldn't be handled I know this because
I went through it something somewhere I
couldn't be handled you know Lee a lot
of people can't handle success
not at any level not at any level what
happens to them
Justin Bieber
Michael Jackson
oh God Rest his soul Prince
was good Prince was good I shouldn't say
his name like that
but your world changes for your
perception so you think that's what that
is is people who are going like the
Lindsay lohans and and whoever you want
to say they just can't handle their
success they're going crazy at first
it's this perception man
it's this perception and in the back of
your mind I can't imagine you think that
you're doing something nobody else has
ever done
and in the meantime they're blowing
smoke up your ass I think about the time
Ronda Rousey got kicked in the head
and she just sat on that mat
and people kept saying she's dizzy she
wasn't dizzy
she was thinking
she was thinking about all the [__] she
bought into
and all the lies and all the [__]
[__] people told them the smoke they
blew up her ass how an all her training
she didn't get prepared for this
or maybe that
all the media things she had to do
and all the time that was invested in
talking to people and meeting with
people and talking about movies your
mind got taken away from the [__]
main focus
it's like getting arrested when they put
the handcuffs on you what's the old
adage that a cop knows if you're guilty
or innocent
because the guilty guy he goes to bed
like a baby
that's it he got caught
the innocent guy is up thinking how's he
gonna get out of this [__] mess
that's really crazy yeah that would be
my first instinct too with like how
would I fix it when I got sentenced I
stole a little under a gram of blow
and I fell asleep for about an hour in
the jail cell while they came and got me
to process me maybe an hour and a half I
fell asleep and I mean a sleep with
drool coming out of my [__] mouth
and that's when I realized I go holy
[__]
you know that's it this is it this is my
favorite so you didn't have anxiety
about being in prison you're just like I
deserve it they caught me that's it
that was it at that point everything
else was [__] once that judge said
six she is didn't mean [__] once I
walked in there and I took my [__]
handcuffs off and I sat in that cell
that's where the walls fell in on me
and it was the weirdest thing because
the wars fell out on me
and
the walls fell on me
I went through this Panic a little bit
of attack like your life flashing in
front of your eyes
and I took my jacket off I had a suit
you know and I had his college shirt
with no t-shirt underneath but I got
that heat that anxiety heat you get I
took that jacket off
and I I don't know if I breathe through
it I know I didn't pass out and I was
alone and there was a camera on me
and as I'm patting the jacket on my leg
Lee I could feel something in the jacket
I thought it was a button
and I went to flip the jacket up and I
stuck my head on the left side
and there it was I could feel a [__]
baggie
and I said I hope this is [__] empty
and I put my hand up so the camera
wouldn't see it I left it in his hand
and it had like a little rock and the
rest of it was powder I remembered what
batch that was and everything at that
moment like when I got it like in July I
got sentenced in August and it has been
in that suit since July
no I had gone to court before in that
suit you did not bring Coke to courtly
dog I was out of my [__] bird and I
crushed it up I crushed it up I took my
wallet out I took a dollar bill out I
had in my wallet like a 20 or 10 God
knows what I had in there I didn't have
no 100 to nothing and I rolled up like a
five whatever the [__] it was and I did
that whole package on one snort you
didn't they wouldn't see you they didn't
see me I may believe I was pissing and I
went into the sink like I was washing my
hands so the camera was over my back
I put the dollar bill in hand I put it
already in the package so I put it up to
my nose and I snorted it opened the
dollar bill wet it and I flushed the
dollar bill with the [__] package
just in case dog you know I don't [__]
around
you flush the dollar bill everything
what was I going to do with I'm in
prison what do I need a dollar bill what
was I gonna do what's a dollar gonna
[__] do for me so I flushed it and I
sat on the thing and leave within
20 minutes I passed that
and you're just relaxed
like like what happened what what went
through your head when you woke up and
realized that you're falling asleep in
prison
once I heard my name
there was nothing I could do or think
that that's it I was I was a beaten man
everything had surrendered like all the
thoughts I had had for the last 16
months or whether or not or what was I
going to do with my life this was it
now I had to start thinking about what
the [__] was I going to do now
I'm not gonna lie to you like four days
later I started calling my then
girlfriend and my attorney and seeing if
we could put something together to get
me out of there but within a week I knew
I was doing there was no gonna I wasn't
gonna Escape
I'm not that [__] dumb I was gonna
Escape or nothing like that did you did
you at that point know there was
probably gonna be like a year and a half
or however long you ended up doing or
did you think it was gonna be the full
six years
I thought about two years I thought it
was going to be about two years so you
didn't even really know but I also knew
something else that he had said
something to my attorney he told my
attorney to file a reconsideration
letter
right off the bat he told my attorney
then
the judge the motion the motion couldn't
get served for 120 days which means four
months
so I knew I was doing four months at
least
and I knew that even if I went to court
after four months that's [__] so I
got sentenced in August
all right all right so that's what's
four months that's December what happens
in December the holidays yes it's a slow
debt yeah and then the hearing was
scheduled for January 20th
today the president he didn't got it he
got in uh what is what's that called
inaugurated right
so it was 1989 January 20th
because I remember sitting in the cell
waiting to go to court
and going
the Community Corrections people said
nope will not take on
oh you're so you're trying to get out of
prison somehow I was trying to get the
sentence reduced to six years community
service six kids six years Community
correction what does that mean which
means that they put you in a halfway
house or
a work release program
you have to stay clean have a job go to
school
and after then you have to petition the
court again and then they let you go
home but you still have those six years
hanging over your head and if you do
something [__] up
they put you back in jail for the
remaining around that time
that's scary to think about so what
happened was
Community Corrections turned me down
just immediately and the probation
department turned me down
but guess what else happened
what happened
I had done five months
so five months so what happens is when
you go to prison you go to prison under
a number of bases
Okay so
you're allowed to file
for the halfway house
the 18th month
you're eligible for halfway house at 18
months for your first six years
no
is everyone else okay so six years okay
so let me let me do it for you so six
years all right right tomorrow you go to
[__] jail
you get six years six times twelve is
what 72 right what's half of 72 36.
you're going to do 36 months right if
it's non-violent okay if it's a violent
crime you're gonna do three quarters of
your sentence
if it's non-violent first offender you
behave yourself you get your high school
diploma you join the band you join the
choir you do all your therapy and you
pay your restitution
that's the most important thing that you
pay your restitution so you got 36
months okay
so let's say my situation
so it's three years
in my situation it was zero to six
they gave me four
so that's 48 months okay
48 months divided into two is what 24. I
did a month in County a month in County
Council for two what's that making 22 22
months
I did five months what does that put me
at 17. oh so anything uh okay just
follow me
[__] December
one day I'm talking to my counselor goes
oh by the way I put you in for a halfway
house over there what the [__] are you
talking to me goes yeah you're eligible
they have a computerized calendar they
submit you right away
now they got to decide where they're
going to take you they have to take you
and there's no turning you down
they have to take you just as soon as
the bed opens up or something as soon as
the bed opens up
so once I went back they transferred the
sentence to four years or they did
something they transferred the sentence
Community Corrections and he sentenced
uh he knocked off something
they knocked off something so but or it
was already too late
I was already up for a halfway house in
December they had already put me up for
Halfway House in December so now they
were just waiting for a [__] bed
So within a week I got a call and hey
BCTC took it
Boulder County Treatment Center took me
and did you have to pay for the halfway
house [__] yeah but the beauty of it was
oh yeah the run the beauty of it was it
was either the BCTC or lctc
and lctc really wanted me lcdc's
Longmont Community treatment center and
[__] Longmont oh at that time Loma was a
cow town but Lee they're the best tacos
I ever ate in my [__] life at the
prisons no at the [__] that there was
a store
called uh something
Lee I used to drive from Bold anyway
everything they were 89 cents a piece I
would get 22.
I would just give it whatever I had in
my pocket give me tacos
machaca with eggs with just deli ShoSho
tacos in Longmont Colorado when I was
waiting to get sentenced I would work at
Hertz rent a car and they would say go
to the Longmont pick up a car that was
music to my ears
because you got to stop there every day
I got jobs in Longmont after that Valley
Subaru sprinkler Auto Sales just the
[__] work just to be able to go to
delicioso
that's how I was [__] bang a lot in
those days is it still open I think so
will I take you there I don't know I
don't know if it's the same owners hell
I don't know if it's the same breakfast
tacos I don't know what the [__] goes on
there
so that's what saved me
so when I got back I was out of that
[__] thing by February I was already
in the halfway house anyone in July
oh yeah
boom I was already in halfway house
that's I don't know I don't know because
for some like obviously I know you and
you're a good person but
it is kind of scary that some of these
people who are you think are going away
for a while
aren't going away for as long as you
think they are
no and that's what I tell people this is
all [__]
I love when they arrest people and they
make those statements on television
about somebody excuse me
sorry about that I love when you're
watching the news
and somebody says oh my God major drug
bust the rest tonight and the whole
south side of of you know what West
Hollywood
least I had it got arrested with three
kilos and uh forty two thousand thousand
cash
and they say he had an estimated value
of Street cocaine at three point million
and you sit there and go
let's figure this out in my day I would
snort coke and do math for hours to
figure them out but then I talked to a
detective and they told me how they did
it do you have those notebooks no I put
those on fire oh I would sit there for
hours and do math
I could have I have one witness that's
still alive that could call in here and
tell you that for 10 hours I would sit
there snort blow and become [__]
Copernicus what sort of family do you do
okay like okay so up for the cases maybe
I was still doing math and two thought
when I got the longest yard I was doing
that
like I would figure out the scenes I was
doing and how much each scene they were
paying me like I was that [__] at
night on the blow I would get that
[__] [__] on the Block I really
think Owen Benjamin abandoned the ship
he is the first guest
that has ever abandoned it
I don't know I think he's out there I
could see it there was one point where I
could see his eye just go thank God he
said no one on the second one yeah he
would have been dead
well actually I I kind of think the body
kind of like pushes back at that point
but maybe not maybe he would be
no it happened this listen man I thought
I asked him if he could smoke dope he
said yes
and then he said can I take a star it's
there you know you want to start take
them but then he saw me in lead and then
he goes if you guys are gonna eat six of
them I might as well take another one
guys you know me at home I will give you
as many stars as you want as long as you
eat them in front of me I want to see a
disaster happen in front of me I live
for that [__] I live for that [__] he's
six foot [__] seven 200 pounds I
didn't think the star that was gonna
kill him now by the way this kid's a
great kid what I was telling you guys
about this guy at home I'm not
bullshitting it there's like a couple
people that when I see yeah
I behave myself
and he's one of them because he's such a
[__] sweetheart Everyone likes him
from what I've heard everybody yeah
nobody has a bad word to say about this
home Benjamin kid I listen I was leaving
the store up three weeks ago
I was about to get in my car and when
I'm going to the car I don't hear
nothing hey hello there's no retreating
there's no retreating it's over
I heard I saw him and I gotta tell you
something he brightened my day there's
few people that brighten my day like
this this kid does his nervous as a bad
word he's a funny guy he works [__]
hard he's out every [__] night
you know he's done some big [__]
movies so if you get a chance to go see
your own go down there bring him an
edible tell them the church Center
that's it he'll [__] love it and
we'll get him back in we'll get him to
talk some [__] let me give some shout
out to you at least I am
first off to my main people Greg and
Lynn Powers my main man it's SF John
Cutler I couldn't see him this last
weekend my main man in Bakersfield Matt
Baker over that Bakersfield BJJ teaching
[__] the true Jitsu to the next
level
Tammy Burbank burback Thomas Easter I'll
see Thomas damana at the Laugh Factory
hope we don't stab somebody and they
don't get banned from there Melissa Eva
Perez my family in Chicago Bob lalingus
and [__] I'm shooting my special day
October 22nd Chicago why
because you're bad [__] and
there's no better Club than Rosemont
[__] Chicago so I'm shooting my
special at Rosemont it's [__]
official tickets are not on sale yet uh
I gotta figure out how to get to the
link look the the Lingus family of
[__] uh uh lee who who shot [__]
Lincoln
there
My Man Mark Walsh Shad Risa Crystal
Johnson over there looking good in
[__] Utah and my main man Troy
Wallace Evans and [__] always giving you
some love I'm gonna be in Sacramento
this weekend and next weekend I'm
[__] thrilled to say I'm going to one
of my favorite cities Pittsburgh
Pennsylvania
I'm gonna go to [__] primantis
whatever the [__] it is I'm gonna
[__] walk around I'm gonna go rub the
Roberto Clemente statue
the whole thing you understand me I
don't give a [__] Lisa and I'm having a
good time I'm writing everything's
coming to pieces
I'm writing three things at once you
know my comedy is kind of weird right
now because I'm in the middle of a
[__] I'm like a butterfly what's a
butterfly before he becomes a butterfly
caterpillar a caterpillar no that
process oh uh cocoon I'm on a cocoon
process right now you know what I'm
saying I'm trying to push [__] together
I don't even know why I drew that
nicotine gum I gotta do it with coffee
if not it doesn't work anything it's
like cocaine without alcohol it just
don't work you gotta do the [__] yay
you got a drink you're gonna look out
the window
you call your mother for Mother's Day
I send her flowers flowers in the cut
what the [__] what is wrong with you
what are you gonna go see you're gonna
go back yeah I'm going to go back in
November absolutely bullshitting with me
[__] yeah because now that you went back
in June I'll take one of my Freaks and
[__]
there's a freak I understand no I'm
excited she's happy uh
got her some nice flowers those it was
good Mother's Day
nice I tried to do something nice for my
wife
I was sad the last two [__] days
you know I had a I'm writing this uh a
chapter in the book right now
and
supposed to have three chapters
and then we could sell the book and then
we have to write the book in a certain
amount of time
it's not at this point
that I'm a bad writer I know the stories
it's really coming together for the
first time that's awesome for me and
some days it's uh
I put eight sentences in but I take two
out or you know what I'm saying like
it's always something like that
but the other day on Mother's Day I
wanted to read
the I didn't read the whole chapter I
just read
the uh
part where I go out and I come home and
I'm on acid and
I go to bed and I get up in the middle
of night and I hear her and I get up to
pee and I go down I find my mother dead
her arm is purple and you know I kind of
sit there and I wrote that out again
and in my mind I felt like I was
supposed to be upset you know what I'm
saying like I was supposed to be upset
you ever feel like that like you might
be upset but I really wasn't upset I was
really proud that I got to write it how
I finally wanted to [__] write it so
you didn't get emotional anymore not at
all you know I'm trying to write the
aftermath now
which really uh takes away from that
chapter that chapter is such a strong
little piece of writing that after that
you just close the book and put it down
for an hour and go I don't really want
to know what happens next
at what point do you think you got like
were able to not get emotional would it
be like last year is it just this like
how many years ago did it take because
that's what about Mother's Day I'm away
from my mom I started to think about
when she's not going to be here and I
get sad I got bad news for you in life
when you lose a friend the relative will
love them the Pain's always there
always that always stays for you
especially my mother
the pains
the Pain's always that's like being poor
and having a toothache
you learn to live with
you want to see somebody who's drinking
and have like a [__] up missing tooth
that tooth was [__] up for two years
but he had to decide between booze or a
dentist
and he picked the [__] he picked
booze I did the same thing with blow
you know I had to pick between a 50
piece of Coke or paying the dentist what
the what would you do I I picked [__]
the 50 piece of blow and I took an
aspirin and shoved it in the [__]
cavity for the you know that's how
[__] up my teeth were in the back I
would just get an aspirin and put it in
my tooth
there was a hole in your tooth yeah bare
aspirin put it in my tooth
and then once it really started hurting
I got a bottle of Jack one of those
little pints and I drink it half of it
straight and then I just take the
[__] tooth or whiskey I'm lying to
you I wouldn't drink Jack I'd take like
Chivas one of those whiskeys that has
like a sour taste to it
and I would just pull the [__] tooth
out
this whole side is shaking the back
and I had the abscess one time I got
really sick and bold and I went over to
to the [__] place and the hospital
they yanked the rest of it out
but what do you think those people feel
like it's the same thing when you lose a
relative or a mom or something
more and more I'm getting more I get
calls at least every six months
from somebody who says Hey man can I
talk to you about something
I had a kid hunt me out the kid who I
stayed with
from [__] 30 years ago Hunted Me Out
to tell me his father died
and that one night he was thinking now
that he understood me and how could I
live with that at an early age
that he really got a whole new respect
for me for even living with that pain
I have a teacher that is for Mr Brown
his mother died I heard he's in a
horrible place right now wrong [__]
man
grown [__] man
grown [__] man you never prepared for
none of this [__]
that's the part of life
you're never prepared for
listen I like Prince
I like the music was I a big [__] no no
I you know somewhere along the line I
stopped listening to a lot of music and
I listened to whatever Prince put on the
radio
but I didn't know his albums like I know
other bands albums I know Purple Rain
and I know the one after that
but that was it after I think like a 90
I tapped from Prince
you know do I feel yes I can't imagine
what Prince's family and his friends
feel like people really knew him not
those [__] people that go on extra
and tell you the lies you know
that's the worst part of that that's the
part of that that destroys me
the [__] [__] you got to put up
with and [__] people talking you know
who the [__] are you
how does he know you what the [__] are
you talking about
but you know it's accepted you know what
I'm saying it's like putting rip on your
Twitter stop don't make me go over there
and get you canceled
what is canceled from what I don't know
I'm just talking [__] here [__] Lisa
Adam I'm nine stars and you're not nine
thousand maybe seven who's counting I'm
counting what do you think I don't have
no Edibles in my system from last night
or the day before or the day before you
know I'm a [__] horse with that I
ain't got time for this [__] what the
[__] I'm sorry I'm sorry what are you
saying what are you apologizing for you
never apologize I have no idea you're my
[__] family you never [__]
apologize and that's it I can't really
believe when Benjamin left I love it
listen this is just another feather in
our cap
you gotta I'm gonna Forget It Was 1980
[__] four so you put the camera on
his chair when you say this it was 1984.
and uh
North Bergen people will get the bad
reputation there was a bar called
Corky's
at the time had switched governments it
was called Gregory seven-day weekend and
I got to tell you something looking back
at that bar it just became a cocaine
storm
at at 1 30 in the morning on a Friday
Saturday Thursday Tuesday if you just
went in that car if you went in that bar
with a camp
and you put it on and you could have
sold that show today
if there was 40 people in there 40 of
them's jaw were going from side to side
smoking cigarettes you couldn't hear
from the [__] bar you couldn't you
know
what's the point of my story I have no
[__] like dealing look Gregory seven
day weekend it could be a TV show
oh if he's back on Benjamin maybe he
just went for a walk in the neighborhood
said [__] let me just go for a walk and
walk it off
and when you were a kid you got kicked
in a [__] stomach your teacher would
say walk it off [__]
yeah I just hope he's okay I'm sure he's
fine
I'll call him after this is over getting
the [__] out of here anyway what else we
got to do tonight Lee remind me remind
me we got to read some [__] ads here
as usual my main people over at Nature
Box listen
what the [__] you know what I'm saying
the Church of What's Happening Now is
brought to you by NatureBox dedicated to
making smart delicious snack and easy
you deserve better than high fructose
corn syrup potato chips and all that
[__] NatureBox snacks taste delicious
without any high fructose corn syrup
trans fat MSG artificial colored
sweetness or flavors none of that crap
NatureBox makes finding a range of
options from healthy to indulgent to
easy they combine unique flavors with
ingredients you can pronounce to create
great snacks you may not want to share
with nobody from Sriracha roasted
cashews to the peanut butter num Noms
are you kidding me or what nature boxes
over a hundred seriously delicious
options to choose from all delivered
right to your door that's the beauty of
this and you'll never get bored with
NatureBox snacks because every single
month they release new snacks to choose
from like uh the chocolate nut the dark
cocoa Nom Noms delicious they move the
plantains I didn't see the plantains but
you know me I'm a sucker for the salt
and pepper lentil whoops that's how I
roll all the garlic bread cheese chips
anyway don't worry about that let's
start with this say goodbye to weird
mystery ingredients and start snacking
confidently with NatureBox go to
naturebox.com Joey to get 50 off your
first box I'm telling you this is good
[__] go to naturebox.com right now go to
naturebox.com Joey and get right snacks
for 2016. you want to look good you're
two months away from putting a bikini on
your little pussy's gonna be hanging out
you don't want no blubber hanging over
who's gonna [__] eat that thing one
last time that's naturebox.com slash
Joey for 50 off your first box of
delicious
high quality snacks sent directly to
your [__] doorstep you
understand me I also want to welcome
that's uh that's susara geez they got
hemp gear high quality functional gear
hemp textile it's like [__] cotton
mixed they got towels they got fighter
geese they got bags they got hooded
sweatshirts do me a favor got go to
dotsusara.com right now and look at the
fine selection of stuff they got they
got two beautiful geese men and women
[__] beautiful right they also
sponsor ebi and one and all listen last
week I flew from Indianapolis
and Tuesday night I went to The Comedy
Zone
and on the way out
some black dude came up to me
he looked familiar
interesting
and he had a white girlfriend and he had
another buddy with him
and we took a few pictures in the middle
of all this
he says you know she is and I go no I
don't and he goes she's like this thing
with vapor pens
and all of a sudden she goes give it to
him and he takes out a vape but he puts
on a new pen he takes it she takes it
and I took it
you realize I was driving away I could
feel tingling my throat
I went home I inhaled 6 000 milligrams
of vitamin C
just to sleep it you know what I'm
saying I drank some Waters in my heart
wouldn't have
and I took two [__] of those pills
shroom tax I also took two before I flew
and two when I tapped down because you
always got to take care of yourself when
you fly I drank a bunch of water
I felt something for a few days I felt
something Wednesday I caught myself
sleeping in the afternoon Wednesday and
I couldn't figure out what it was it was
that I was going over something again I
inhaled vitamin C I took some mushroom
Tech it finally hit me Friday night
Saturday morning I had a little bit by
the time I got off stage the county
store it was gone
shroom Tech was the way to go you want
shrimp tack you want shrimp Tech sport
you want shrimp Tech immune you got to
go to honest.com right now while you're
there take a look at [__] Alpha brand
while you're there take a look at the
ham protein take a look at this [__]
read the ingredients see how hard Aubrey
works for you [__] if there's
something you like go to the box and
press in church get 10 off your first
order delivered right to your door it's
that easy I'm not going to sit here and
blow smoke up your ass because I don't
have to Alpha Brain you don't like it it
don't work for you you get 100 money
back guarantee and they don't want the
product back that's the type of
confidence they got in this [__] go to
Alpha Brain dot go to
newton.com go to the box and press in
church and get 10 off I want to thank
NatureBox I want to thank Anna and I
want to thank drsara.com the best geez
in the business I mean there's some
great geez out there but this is a
spectacular gee lightweight it feels
great go to Dr Sarah right now and look
at the fine selection of geese they got
all right that's it I want to thank my
man oh and Benjamin we [__] tried we
tried he came in and dabbled at the
[__] king of swing and his main
Goomba Lisa yeah and this is what goes
down okay Spooky's watching you know you
can't you know when okay Spooky's
watching you can't come in here if you
haven't taken anything no you can't do
it
oh who's that maybe his wife
now
I'm gonna hold on we're gonna bother us
you know I'm saying we got the World by
the balls they say yeah we'll be back
Wednesday what do you got planned for
tomorrow
I have uh hopefully life in neutral a
giant rock and then
um an everyday cannabis with uh
my good buddy up there look at you're
the man of many [__] podcasts fine
you're like 19 [__] podcasts who's
better than you anyway I'll be in
Sacramento this weekend rocking the
house with Felicia Michaels and next
weekend I'll be at the Pittsburgh
[__] improv I want to thank
Owen Benjamin I think it's on
benjamin.com whatever he's a great kid
man these stars are [__] brutal trust
me he's not the first one to tap out and
I want to thank my main man Lisa and I
want to thank you guys for listening
have a great week and thank you for the
love and support Uncle Joey out I see
you [__] on Periscope this week
stay black